where in the hell are you
[Music]
hey this is Justin sorry I couldn't get
to you right now please leave your name
and number and I'll get back to you as
soon as possible thanks
hey babe
oh look I'm sorry but I mean you need to
come home because it is like starting to
rain really bad out there I don't want
you like driving around
I mean let's just come home and talk
about it
this isn't how a marriage is supposed to
be I mean you're not supposed to storm
off and be all mad now I'm all like
mad because he left he needs to learn
that he needs to sit down and talk about
his feelings every once in a while
all right
oh I see you made it home Hans
yeah
so how's things going yeah and things
are going
I'm so glad that he made it home safe
but I know exactly what I'm gonna do to
make up it's something Justin started 16
months ago and it's random dancing and
no matter how mad we are at each other
or matter how bad the day is each one of
us can grab each other and random dance
and it works every time watch I love the
dancing and the little things with June
but like she really needs to understand
that like this is not a joke if she
cannot change her ways I will not do
this relationship anymore
how'd you go I just needed a minute now
we just need a minute you say sorry it's
just my way of saying sorry I don't
understand your way of thinking
well it's compromise not just do what
June wants but it's okay I'm sorry
you know that I'm trying to rebuild the
relationship with mama dukes and he lied
to her
well I mean I listen to your mom no my
kids weren't gonna come to the bridal
shower they might show up well you know
please try not to make me have to lie to
my mom again because like that's really
put me in a rough place and
I don't want to have to pick between
wife or Mama